the man who says he was the victim of a
racially motivated attack at an Indiana
Lake is talking to CBS News along with
an eyewitness it's a story we first
brought to you yesterday and we want to
remind our viewers that what you see and
hear here is disturbing vox Booker said
a group of white men surrounded him and
threatened to get a noose much of the
confrontation was caught on video as you
can see here our national correspondent
Jericka Duncan is following the
investing investigation jurika good
morning we're told the FBI is now
involved what do we know good morning
Tony that's right according to Booker's
attorney the FBI is investigating
whether or not this was a hate crime but
the bureau would not elaborate so how
did all of this start well Booker says
he was headed to the lake with a couple
of friends to watch the lunar eclipse on
July 4th when a confrontation turned
violent was happening 36 year old watts
Booker a local civil rights activist
from Bloomington Indiana says a group of
white men pinned him against a tree
shouted racial slurs and threatened to
lynch him it happened near Lake Monroe
just outside of Bloomington on the 4th
of July much of the assault was captured
on cell phone video by witnesses Booker
says the assault came after some of the
men allegedly made statements about
white power he says he decided to start
a conversation with him in an effort to
keep the peace but he says within about
three minutes things got out of control
I'm going to take this energy and take
this moment to make sure
Booker's friend Ian Watkins who says he
tried to help claims he was attacked - I
tried to pull him off and he punched me
warhead and knock me down to the ground
a couple times I felt like I was his
only line of defense so I stepped in to
try to help him as best I could
once Booker was let go he says there
were
more racist insults investigators
confirmed two of the suspects as 38 year
old Jerry Cox and 44 year-old Shawn
Purdy Bloomington Mayor John Hamilton I
saw the videos late Sunday night and I
have to say they turned my stomach it
was a hate crime I do in our country
racism exists it is real it's been
around for centuries and it's still here
and we need to address it openly and
directly we reached out to Cox and Purdy
for common Cox did not respond but
pretty responded by sending us a message
of a former police officer who's black
and gave his account about why he thinks
Booker's story is skeptical meanwhile
the prosecutor's office will ultimately
decide if any charges will be filed Gale
tarika turned my stomach to I'm confused
as to why there's a question that it's a
hate crime and once again as disturbing
as that video is I'm very glad there is
a video that we can see what has
happened yeah what's so interesting too
is the man in that video Booker said
that he would do it all again you know
he said that a lot of the support he's
received is why he says he would have
made the same decision to try and talk
to these people about alleged comments
they made that were racist you have to
keep reminding myself it is 20 20 people
it is 20 20 thank you Jerrica